We're all persuading
all the time.
Sales and persuasion
is part of our lives.
It's like the weather.
No matter what you
do, you are in sales.
I've spent the last 20 years
researching and writing
about two obsessions
in my life--
persuasion and motivation.
Persuasion is not some
kind of magical thing
that we do to manipulate people.
It's not about tricking people.
It's actually more
beautiful than that.
Whether you are an entrepreneur
trying to raise money,
whether you're an employee
trying to convince your boss,
whether you're a parent
trying to persuade your kid,
I'm going to show
you how to do that.
This approach is
built on science.
I want to show you
how our brains work.
There's a lot of
research on mimicry.
Waiters and waitresses who
repeated the order back word
for word earned 70% more tips.
Mimic people's language and
you'll see a difference.
I think a lot of people approach
pitching in the wrong way.
Two scholars went to a whole
set of Hollywood pitch meetings
to see what was effective
and what was not.
If you look at the research,
it is overwhelming.
The pitches that were
effective invite the other side
in as a collaborator,
period, full stop.
A cognitive bias is a
glitch in the human mind.
We all are subject to it.
We have to watch for it.
Because in 99 times out of 100,
it's going to lead us astray.
If you think about sales
and persuasion and influence
in a fresh way, you can be
extraordinarily effective
and do something
really important
for the world, other people,
and ultimately yourself.
I'm Daniel Pink and
this is my MasterClass.